同件は何倍にするそうだな俺は5倍に
しようかな5倍結構やれねダイキ辛いの
苦手だったっけうん大好きだけどここ市
からいてなんか異常じゃないなぁそれは
わかる0倍は甘口とほぼ変わらんけど1倍
からいきなりナパームだねブレ店だったら
なんで5倍にする逆に1杯でも食べてすぐ
下の感覚がなくなるから同棲ナパーム弾を
組んだったらってことまあそうだなじゃあ
10倍にしたらでもそれがねぇ食べてる
ときは違いを測るんけど翌日トイレに入っ
たときは怒る
痛いほど音や空前に言うならじゃあ聞く
なるポテトいるいる何はなぁもはいらん
分かった
すみませんな憧憬英語で話していいやダメ
だ俺にも外国人の友達を作ろうとしてて
いやちょっと待って今度外人バーとかに
入って誰かに話しかけてみようと思ってて
なるほどねでもねぇたい外国人と
めちゃくちゃ話したくてや大喜ストップ
ストーンと言ってることおかしいよそうか
なすでにが行く6人の友達いるじゃんんい
るっけ
すごく
でもかなチャンハーフだからなんか違うか
なチャンじゃなくて俺だから外国人と話し
たいとかって言ってるんだけどもう20分
前から外国人と話してるからそうだけど
同行は何か日本人じゃどういう状況だっ
たら外国人と話してるって事になるどう
いう状況だから外人バーで出会った人が俺
みたいな人だったら満足するそうかそれは
考えてなかったと言っちまって日本語を
話す外国人は外国人ぽくないって思うそう
思うよを張ってあったら大毅は全然日本人
ぽくなんで俺は日本で生まれて日本で刀
持ってないかそれとこれは違うなり今の
生活に退屈してるから新しい刺激が欲しい
そういうことだいやをフェは単純にしかし
残念ながら外国人に様だけで何かこう新海
誠の映画みたいにタイムスリップが起こっ
たり急に夢灯路が流れたりするわけじゃ
ないから外国人友達をつくって本当に刺激
が欲しいんだったら大貴こそカレーを10
倍にしてちょっとした地獄味わった方が
いいんじゃなますそうだな
そうする
でもそれなら何も言わん
me